CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman
joins us at the table to discuss you
know the charges Ricky OH pretty
disgusting but they've been discussing
for a long time in his attorney one of
his attorneys is saying this is
essentially a do-over so do you think
it's that and if not what makes us
different
well the expected defense move would be
to say we'll file a motion to dismiss
because this has all been litigated
before and he was given immunity back in
2008 by the Southern District of Miami
in the federal prosecution when a 53
page indictment just went away it was
dismissed he got to do 13 months on one
state count of a solicitation of
prostitution so he went from being a
predator to simply being a John of the
thirteen months by the way oh my god he
went six days a week six days a week so
what you have what you have now is the
defense says this is a do-over we
already got immunity Southern District
of New York simply says look he had an
agreement with the Southern District of
Florida that does not bind the Southern
District of New York that's going to be
the biggest piece of litigation here and
now they are looking for new victims so
they may have some new charges how big
it let's talk about this plea deal which
which has been criticized from the
get-go it's appalling it is appalling
well because you have a sex trafficking
indictment with multiple victims it goes
away and the victims are never informed
about it it was done in secret so if
it's done in secret why would you do
that well because it was really a
terrible terrible plea deal so the
individual who negotiated that plea deal
Alexander Acosta is now labor secretary
in the Trump administration he was
grilled about that deal by Congress but
was approved what's next for him well he
changed it yeah I think he is right
greatly tainted and I think there will
be a groundswell you have to remember
the change of time and change of culture
at the time 2008 when people were
victims in situations like this they had
shame now because of the me2 movement
now they have courage so Alex Acosta
becomes
public enemy number two Jeffrey Epstein
being number one but number two because
he did the sweetheart deal and it is
going to be looked at and dissected and
I think Alex Acosta needs to talk to his
family and have a big reconsideration
because already people are calling for
his resignation this sounds very much
like Bryan Stevenson always says that
the justice system works very
differently if you are rich and guilty
than if you are poor and innocent well
unfortunately this is proof positive of
that so I do hope that new victims come
forward and apparently they are all
right Ricky Kleeman